[Music]
how does Eber make money first things
first
uber is a mobile app that connects
potential passengers to dedicated
drivers a cab company for the current
century that allows you to Hale cards
not from the kerb but from the comfort
of your own home technology has taught
us that one demand disrupts old
paradigms an uber is no exception
the company's been stealing passengers
and drivers from companies and City cabs
ever since its launch in 2009 net annual
revenues top 200 million dollars
according to some internal numbers that
leaked recently from the private company
which may soon be worth more than 10
billion dollars that's because ubers
growing fast operating in 120 cities in
36 countries and employing more than 900
people around the world its mobile app
helps answer around a million ride
requests every week taking a 20% cut
from each fare ultimately uber is a
middleman its drivers ferry on-demand
passengers around in limos SUVs even
helicopters Padova doesn't actually own
any of that inventory which helps keep
costs under control and as the company
recruits new part-time drivers with
powerful promises of paydays remember
uber may want you and not just as a pass